madame bonjour merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors on le disait
cette étude elle est inédite et elle
dresse un constat alarmant de la
situation d'une partie des français près
d'un sur trois dit se sentir en
situation de vulnérabilité
et qui sont ces nouveaux vulnérables et
quelles sont les conséquences pour
aujourd'hui
alors ce qui a principalement fragilisé
ces personnes sont des questions
d'emploi
on
dit qu'elles ont beaucoup de mal à se
maintenir dans l'emploi ou à accéder
dans l'emploi donc c'est plutôt des
jeunes actifs en fait qui travaillent
dans le secteur privé plutôt en cdd ou
qui ont été au chômage partiel en
liaison avec avec la crise
et ce qui les caractérise aussi c'est
que souvent ils sont chargés de famille
donc une anxiété aussi qui est au delà
de leurs propres situations personnelles
liées aux conséquences évidemment pour
pourvoir aux besoins de leur famille
alors justement madame hoibian des
français en grande difficulté économique
et pourtant elle est français n'ont
jamais autant épargné le gouvernement
ainsi sur les bonnes perspectives de
croissance est ce que selon vous il
existe de france
oui bien sûr alors sur le plan de
l'épargné en fait il faut savoir que 70
% des parts de cumuler a été accumulée
par 20% des ménages donc on voit bien
qu'il ya une concentration en fait de
cette épargne et c'est assez logique
puisque finalement les dépenses qui ont
pu être évité ces des dépenses de
sorties de loisirs de vacances et six
sont des dépenses qui sont plutôt fait
part des ménages aisés les ménages les
plus modestes
n'ont pas eu finalement ces économies à
la fois parce que leurs dépenses ont pu
même se complexifier parce que certains
types de lieux de vente ont pu être
fermé et donc ils n'ont pas pu avoir
accès à des promotions ou un petit peu
optimiser leur budget et également parce
que malgré tout avec le chômage partiel
même si c'était une formidable sécurité
pour les français il y avait quand même
aussi une petite décote des revenus et
du coucher les publics les plus modestes
ça compte énormément et puis vous parlez
de public modeste des ménages modestes
mais ce qu'il était avant la crise
sanitaire aujourd'hui dans quelle
situation ils se trouvent
alors ce que montre de très nombreuses
études dont la nôtre c'est en fait une
augmentation des inégalités c'est
souvent le cas lors de crises mais là ça
a été particulièrement particulièrement
notable donc à la fois les personnes les
plus modestes mais aussi les femmes les
jeunes les personnes qui étaient au
chômage qui était dans des dents des
travaux dans des métiers qui étaient
plutôt en situation précaire finalement
tout cela qui était déjà un petit peu
sur le fil on le vu leur situation se
fragiliser encore plus et notamment
parce que avec l'isolément relationnel
qui a eu lieu pendant donc près de deux
ans
il ya eu moins de soutien finalement
mécaniquement et donc non seulement les
gens étaient confrontés à des
difficultés mais en plus il avait
beaucoup moins de possibilités de
recourir à des soutiens autour d'eux
autour d'eux concernant l'augmentation
des inégalités dans quelle partie du
territoire on vous parlait beaucoup par
exemple je prends pour exemple le
département de la seine-saint-denis skis
à d'autres territoires en france
qu'elles ont été ceux qui ont été les
plus touchées alors c'est vrai que là où
on repère le plus de ces nouveaux
vulnérables c'est plutôt en ile de
france alors il ya effectivement la
seine-saint-denis mais il ya aussi
toute une activité de tourisme de
spectacles d'événementiel qui était très
présente dans la région parisienne et
qui s'est arrêtée quasiment ou qui a
énormément souffert et qui aujourd'hui
n'a toujours n'est toujours pas reparti
d'une certaine manière comme avant la
crise alors selon l'étude trente-et-une
31% des personnes se sentent aujourd'hui
en situation de vulnérabilité soit 10
points de plus qu'en 2018 ça reviendrait
presque à dire que 8% des personnes
depuis 15 ans soit 4 millions de
français en basculer ces deux dernières
années dans une situation préoccupante
oui tout à fait elle est préoccupante
notamment parce qu'ils sont face à un
cumul de difficultés c'est à dire que
c'est tout le monde en fait d'un dans la
vie peut avoir pas avoir des difficultés
que ce soient liées à des accidents de
parcours ou bien à
des proches qui sont qui sont
vieillissants ou qui sont malades etc
mais là la difficulté de ces personnes
c'est qu'elles ont à faire à faire face
en fait à différents types de problèmes
des problèmes de logement des problèmes
d'emploi des problèmes financiers un
très grand nombre d'entre elles
n'arrivent pas à payer leurs factures et
on sait qu'après ensuite peut se mettre
en place une forme de mécanique un peu
infernal où une fois qu'on n'a pas
réussi à payer ses factures qu'on a pas
réussi à payer son loyer on peut aller
vers l'expulsion locative et c'est à une
fois qu'on a perdu son logement c'est
extrêmement compliqué c'est pour ça
qu'il faut vraiment dès aujourd'hui agir
sur ces publics pour éviter en fait un
basculement dans des situations
inextricables
alors justement on a cette étude du
credoc et puis on a le discours du
gouvernement dans l'impression qu'un
fossé semble se creuser la stratégie du
quoi qu'il en coûte des mayas le
maquereau est ce qu elle a une part de
responsabilité selon vous alors non il
faut plutôt salué cette stratégie du
quoi qu'il en coûte parce que si elle
n'avait pas eu lieu serait été beaucoup
beaucoup plus il faut quand même
rappeler que on a eu une baisse du pib
de l'ordre de 30% lors de la crise de
2008 on était à -3% donc on est quand
même dans une
marais économique sans commune mesure
avec ce qu'on avait connu par le par le
passé donc tous les mécanismes de
soutien qui ont été mis en place ont été
extrêmement efficaces et permettent
aujourd'hui la reprise donc je pense
qu'il faut pas jeter la pierre au
gouvernement sur ce sur ce point par
contre évidemment il faut pas non plus
considérer que la reprise concerne tout
le monde de la même manière et d'une
certaine manière il faut prolonger un
petit peu les mécanismes de soutien
parce que l'étude montre également qui
sont très efficaces c'est à dire que
c'est en agissant au bon moment on
permet aux personnes qui sont en
difficulté de rebondir et donc on évite
que la situation sans piste donc c'était
encore aujourd'hui qu'il ya un des
leviers finalement à mettre en place
pour que la reprise
profite à tout le monde merci infiniment
d'avoir répondu à toutes nos questions
sandra hoibian je rappelle que vous êtes
directrice du pôle société du credoc
mercia au maire